before I'm going to answer the question
what's the difference in predicting
climate change or the weather let's move
to the German Premier League in football
so I'm asking you to think about whether
you could make a prediction of who is
going to win the game on the coming
Saturday and in order to make that
prediction you are likely to consider
how these two teams played over the last
weeks and you will also relatively soon
know whether your prediction was right
or not then on the other hand if I'm
going to ask you who is going to win the
championship in 30 years from now you
are very likely to back off the relation
between soccer and my research is that
if we're looking on the one hand on the
gate on the coming game on Saturday on
in the other hand on the next 30 years
than moving away from soccer I would
describe the weather forecast for next
Saturday or for tomorrow similarly to
the prediction of Saturday's game in the
Premier League also I would describe the
prediction you are likely to make for
who's going to win the championship in
30 years from now to how to predict
climate change if we would like to make
a good weather prediction or a forecast
for tomorrow's weather we need to have a
good description of what today's weather
is like so we need to take into account
all these information about today or the
recent past if on the other hand we're
trying to make a projection of what the
climate is going to be in 30 years we do
not need a specific description of what
the weather is like today but we need a
description of what the overall balances
are if we're going back to the analogy
with the football you might very well be
able to imagine how well we ever might
be able to predict the climate change in
the future because we can mark certain
statements about how the climate is
changing in the future but an accurate
prediction of who is going to win which
match in 30 years from now with players
were some of them they might not even be
born
is absolutely impossible so we face the
same problems in climate prediction
where we can make certain statements
about how the climate is changing but
what that means for a specific region or
what that means for a particular year
were for even for a particular time that
is impossible